- Okay, I've watched the
first episode of "She-Hulk."
- [Hulk] Don't lawyer me.
- Two things stuck out to me.
First is just how terrible
the closing argument was at the end.
- My client was well within his right
to protect his business interest.
These accidental deaths were
an unfortunate byproduct
of an ambitious expansion plan.
- Okay, that's just a terrible argument,
both legally and persuasively,
that a bunch of people died
because you were ambitiously
expanding your business.
That's not gonna work.
- [Lawyer] Did my client know
lives would be in danger?
That is debatable and depends
on your definition of knowing.
- It's a terrible argument that
it depends on the definition
of knowing that other
people are going to die.
That's bad, legally and persuasively.
Just an all around terrible argument
that just seems like they threw
a bunch of legal words together.
But at least there was one bright spot.
At the very beginning of the episode
as they do a slow pull
away from Jennifer Walters,
it's revealed that she has two degrees,
both of which are from UCLA,
obviously the best law school out there.
Go Bruins!